[Musique]
invasion de chauves souris sur paris une
espèce très particulière venu tout droit
des états unis et qui fait des ravages
le virus de la batte magna va t-il se
propager chez les français les
commerçants se préparent au fléau
dans le magasin on va en faire le bad
store c'est à dire qu'on va on va tous
décorés en batman il va y avoir des
crampes batman des affiches de batman il
va y avoir une petite boutique batman
aussi qui sera un peu plus loin derrière
où il y aura une bad girl qui vendra les
les badges les montres les tee shirts
des sacs les lunettes pas tous les
accessoires batman mais attention et mes
héros est une chose rentrer dans une
mode en est une autre
je veux aller à l'école avec un tueur
batman ou un badge avait très gravement
la vérité je trouve ça un peu
dégueulasse qu'on pervertissent un peu
l'image de batman avec des publicités
abusives dans un peu partout on voit des
bas de signal et pour des fans comme
nous on est un peu déçu quoi c'est tout
toute la publicité qu'on a fait autour
bon ça comment s'améliorer et puis parce
que cette recherche de la justice ça
fait un peu gros quoi chez batman
batman ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
depuis dix ans le chanteur piste en vie
dans la peau de son idole
le côté esthétique etc qui m'avait le
plus branché quoi j'ai pas une je vais
pas dormir la tête en bas par exemple
dans ma cage d'escalier
ça fait 50 ans qu'on vénère batman mais
on l'avait un peu oublié les pêcheurs et
il revient pour décrocher le jackpot
livre disque tee shirts badges encore un
disque casquette bande dessinée batman
se décline sous toutes les formes il
doit être possible de s'habiller de
manger de rêver entièrement batman
d'être obsédé par le logo jaune et noir
en forme de chauve souris ou d'amygdales
au choix
je me suis laissé dire que on vous à
cambrioler juste pour vous voler ce
genre de chose oui tu t'es c'est ben
vous voyez derrière moi une niche qui a
été copieusement aménagé vu tous les
produits que nous avions elle a été elle
a été quasiment veulent et en moins de
huit jours et les questions extérieures
du bâtiment ont été aussi cambriolé en
une nuit on a même eu droit à un
commando jeu pagnan suicide mais qui
rentrait dans le cinéma il y avait une
grande silhouette de deux mètres de
batman but de mètres de haut ils sont
rentrés il y en a deux qui ont ouvert
les portes les deux autres ont pris ont
pris la silhouette et sans parti en
courant les uns jamais rattrapé chauffe
qui peut l'ombre du scheer opté à un
justicier plane depuis une semaine sur
le mans son radar légendaire la crau dû
apprendre la sarthe pourquoi tu aimes
city le message que je veux adresser
s'adresse plus particulièrement à tous
les délinquants et les p'tites
fripouilles de tout genre je veille
qu'il fasse attention reçu cinq sur cinq
par le joker son ennemi irréductible
mon rôle ce sera à l'horreur mais
l'horreur avec un grand h comme l'art ce
sera l'art de l'horreur à j'ai commencé
mon opération de terrorisme au mans la
semaine dernière pour la première de
batman
ce couple des étudiants manceaux ne sont
que de pâles réplique des héros de la
warner
juste une animation mise en scène par la
librairie bulle je trouvais très drôle
de pouvoir avoir tout ce qui se faisait
au niveau batman parce qu'il ya quand
même des produits qui sont vraiment très
très sympa bon que ce soient les badges
je les porte clés casquettes tee-shirts
sweats et puis bouquin parce que c'est
quand même ma priorité principale c'est
de vendre de la bande dessinée et de
faire connaître la bandit ni sur le
monde donc bon c'est surtout les
bouquins crème qui passe en premier avec
tout ce déploiement est ce folklore le
culte du gisti et les at il envahit le
mans
nous avons réalisé en première semaine
de 1500 entrées et je pense que tout ça
va aller en augmentant par rapport à la
semaine précédente puisque le film a
fait plus d'entrées mercredi que
mercredi dernier alors est ce qu'on peut
parler de batman y ait au mans oui je
pense qu'on peut en parler et on va en
parler encore plus puisque le film monte
[Musique]